ابطال العالم يصلون وسط العاصمه للاحتفال
مع مئات الالاف وافلام ديزني متهمه بتصوير
الحب بشكل سام وغير واقعي للمراهقين وكوبي
يضرب الصين من جديد والمنصات غرقانه
فيديوهات كاننا نرجعنا 20 20 اهلا بكم
[موسيقى]
نهائي كاس العالم اللعب الاحد لكن ما زال
طبعا العنوان الاول في المنصات فجرا وصل
حامل اللقب المنتخب الارجنتيني لبلاده كان
الاستقبال الحافل وحاشيه طبعا رغم انه
الشمس حتى ما كانت طلعت
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
ومن دقائق كمان وصل المنتخب لوسط العاصمه
للاحتفال مع الجماهير طبعا هذه الصور
مباشره الان من وسط العاصمه الارجنتينيه
بيونس ايروس وطبعا بحسب الاحصاءات الاوليه
يبدو انه في مئه الف مشجع مجتمعين هناك
لحيه المنتخب الارجنتيني اللي فاز للمره
الثالثه
ببطوله كاس العالم وهذه المره فاز على
فرنسا طبعا في احتفاء خاصه
بمسي وفي تقدير خاص لمسي خصوصا انه بهذا
الانجاز يعد انجاز كبير بالنسبه له شخصيا
وعلى مستوى طبعا ايضا المنتخب الصحف
الارجنتينيه اليوم كلها بتتحدث عن ميسي
وتشكره وطبعا ايضا بتتحدث عن وتشييد ايضا
بال المنتخب طبعا في هذا الموقف كمان ايضا
ما ننسى لو الصور كانت دخلت زووم اكثر كنا
هنشوف ايضا انه في كثير من اللي واقفين
حاملين صوره مارادونا الحاضر الغائب في
هذا
الانجاز فطبعا صوره ظهرت في الاحتفالات
محموله وايضا حتى في على الصحف
وكمان خلينا بس نتذكر انه اليوم كان في
اجازه رسميه او اعلن عن اجازه رسميه في
الارجنتين احتفاء بهذا الانجاز
على المنصات ومع الفيديوهات في صور كثيره
كمان متداوله وبتعكس الفرح والنصر
والمراسم الاحتفاليه بالمنتخب الارجنتيني
ومثل ما قلت لكم مشاهدينا تحديدا ميسي
[موسيقى]
ومن وقت المباراه كنا شفنا مقاطع كثيره
لردات فعل لحظه الفوز وكثير منها كانت
رداد فعل جنونيه وصادمه ساعات الماضيه في
مقاطع متداوله من العالم العربي لمشجعين
عرب لمنتخب الارجنتين وردات فول فعلهم على
الفوز
يا حسن
[موسيقى]
حسن حسن
والاحتفالات للاسف مو كلها سعيده في مصر
في شاب عمره 26 سنه مشجع للارجنتين من
فرحته بالفوز اصيب بازما قلبيه حاده وتوفي
هذا غير عدد من المشجعين الارجنتينيين
اللي ماتوا خلال الاحتفالات في الشوارع في
بلادهم
بمناسبه الحديث عن كاس العالم فمع نهايه
الان كمان من الصوت التواصل جلسه بتعمل
ملخصات للي صار عليها من نقاشات حلو وفي
مقدمتهم طبعا تويتر تويتر نشر احصائيات عن
كاس العالم وكشف انه خلال فتره البطوله في
147 مليار امبرشن او انطباع تم تسجيلهم
هذا الرقم تخطى بمراحل الانطباعات خلال
كاس العالم
2018 وحتى يعتبر ضعف انطباعات اولمبياد
طوكيو اما بالنسبه لاكثر اللحظات اللي
جمعت تفاعل خلال كاس العالم وهذه تم
قياسها بعدد التغريدات عن الموضوع في
الدقيقه الواحده في المرتبه الخامسه كان
في هدف نيمار في الدقيقه 106 في مباراه
ربع النهائي مع كرواتيا في المرتبه
الرابعه عندنا هدف دي ماريا اللي كان
الثاني للارجنتين في النهائي والمرتبه
الثالثه برده في الربع النهائي بين
كرواتيا والبرازي واللحظه كانت لحظه تضييع
البرازيل لاخر ضربه جزاء وفوز كرواتيا اما
في المرتبه الثانيه فكان هدف فرنسا الثاني
بقدم مبابي والتعادل في النهائي وطبعا
المرتبه الاولى وكما هو متوقع لحظه نهايه
ضربات الجزاء في النهائي افوز الارجنتين
اكثر اللاعبين اللي تم الحديث عنهم خلال
كاس العالم هما الكوري ساندي ورونالدو
ونيمار ومبابي وميسي اما المنتخب اكثر من
سنه فكان الاول الارجنتين بعدين البرازيل
وفرنسا والبرتغال وكرواتيا وعلى غير تويتر
كمان على فكره حتى جوجل اعلنت تغريده
لرئيسها ان المحرك او انه البحث عن المحرك
سجل اعلى مستوياته في 25 سنه خلال النهائي
وكانه كل العالم في تلك اللحظه كان بيبحث
عن نفس الشيء بحسب كلامه
مشاهدينا خلال اعدادنا الحلقه اليوم مننا
على دراسه لقيناها ملفته جدا الحقيقه
الدراسه اجرتها مجله بي ام سي بابليكال
موضوعها تحليلي عن كيف الاطفال والمراهقين
بيشوفوا الحب والعلاقات والدراسه كان فيها
اصابع اتهام واضحه وصريحه موجهه لافلام
ديزني وغيرها من افلام الكرتون الكلاسيكيه
هذه الافلام من زمان متهمه بتنميه صوره
الفتيات واظهارهم دائما ان سوره الاميرات
اللي بيهتموا بس باللبس والمظهر بيستنو
الامير يجي لهم ويعمل لهم كل شيء كده
وينقذهم انا اتهام جديد لكن اتهام الجديد
اللي بتقول دراسه اليوم هو انه هذه
الافلام بتعطل همم الاطفال والمراهقين
صوره غير حقيقيه عن العلاقات والحب لا بل
وحتى بتعطيهم صوره سامه وبعيده كل البعد
عن صوره العلاقه الطبيعيه وكما يجب ان
تكون الدراسه اعتمدت على مقابلات مع اطفال
مراهقين ومختصين وتوصلت لانه هذه الافلام
بتصور علاقات وحب خيالي او حرفيا مثل
الافلام فارسي ومو موجود في الحقيقه
وبالتالي بيعانوا وبعدين لما يكبروا
وبينصدموا بالواقع وداعه الدراسه كمان الى
انه المدارس في منهجها لازم تبدا تدرس
مواد ومهارات عن العلاقات وكيفيه بنائها
والحفاظ عليها وضمان انها تكون صحيه
وسليمه هتكون معنا من عمان دكتور رشا
التميمي الطبيبه النفسيه اهلا فيك معنا
الدكتوره رشا يعني من البدايه لما الواحد
اخصائيه مش طبيعي
للدراسه واقول لك انه يعني لما الواحد
يشوف الدراسه يقول طيب يعني ايش المشكله
انه يشوفوا قصص حب جميله بتنتهي بالنهايات
جميله
الاطفال يعني
الان يسعد مساكم جميعا بدايه حياتنا همم
عامل خطوره بهذه المحتوى بهذا المحتوى
سواء كان من الافلام ديزني او حتى من
افلام من شركات اخرى وصلنا عليها هذه لهذه
الافلام والمسلسلات لانه احنا الان همم في
فتره الخمس سنوات ست سنوات حتى ما بعد ذلك
نحن الان امام تشكيل شخصيه الطفل والطفله
وما بعد ذلك هي فعلا مراهقه تبنى بهذه
المرحله افكار
تصورات وبنحكي لها احنا يعني افكار مخططات
فكريه همم من تعاملات الفرد مع اهله من
تعاملات الفرد في مدرسته مما يرى من وسائل
الاعلام كما نعلم الان وسائل الاعلام
وتاثيرها على الاطفال على المراهقين مش زي
زمان كانت زمان برامج الاطفال تفتح ساعه
او ساعتين فقط على ايامنا كانوا يحضروا
حياتهم الطبيعيه الان صار الاساس هو هذه
المسائل التواصل او هذا المحتوى
والاستثناء انه يقوم الطفل مثلا يلعب او
يشوف اقارب ومثلا يقوم بامر اخر فالخطوره
انه تكوين شخصيه الفرد هنا تبدا منها
المرحله الان ما ذكرتيه جميل ولكن في حال
كان في همم يعني حد او جزء او همم مستوى
من المراقبه ومن التفاعل مع من الاهل مع
الطفل او همم او اليافع في ماذا يرى من
المحتوى يعني اذا كان في تعليق دائم اذا
كان في هناك مراقبه طبعا مش مراقبه
بالحثيثه بشكل
لا ياخذه على على ايجابيات وسلبياته يعني
معلش يعني هذه النقطه يعني انا باتفرج
مثلا على همم سندريلا واقول لها حبيبتي
ترى في الحياه ما راح يجيك همم
بيبحث عنك بهذا الشكل وترى الحياه نكده
وحتتخانق وممكن يكون سيء ليه اعمل كده
لا انا ما بحكي لانه راح يكون سيء كمان
كمان لما احكي لها انه راح يكون سيء هون
انا بعطيها فكره ممكن انها تولد عندها ما
يسمى لاحقا بال في تشققات المعرفيه يعني
احنا ما بدنا ندخل به توقعات لا ايجابيه
زائد عن الحد النظاره الورديه اللي بنحكي
عنها ولا سلبيه زائده عن الحد احنا بدنا
نتعامل بشكل واقع يعني انه لما الطفل اللي
ذكرته اللي ذكرته عنها قصه سندريلا انه
بالحياه الواقعيه همم ما بيحدث دائما اصلا
عدد الامراء مش مش كثير كبير لهالدرجه انه
يكفي عدد البنات عندنا في المدينه او في
البلد وهذا ما بيحدث يعني دائما الا ب-
بشكل
العبره من القصه ان البنت تكون على
طبيعتها تكون رقيقه تكون طيبه فا احنا مش
ضروري انه نعطيها القصه كامله تاخذها كما
هي بالعكس انا هون يعني هاي فرصه انه نشجع
ال- ال- الاطفال ذكوره حتى لي عفرين انه
يولد عندهم التفكير النقدي انه انا ما اخذ
الشيء على علته زمان كان مثلا المعلم
الاطفال الاولاد بيصير عندهم فكره خطا
بسبب صوره سندريلا وسنووايت
بسبب تنامل بسبب هذا المحتوى ولكن عندما
يعني بتفاعل مع امور اجتماعيه مع تفاعلات
اجتماعيه بتعزز هذا التفكير النمطي او
القالب الاجتماعي
راح يطلعها من الهم اللي في ممكن او راح
ينقلها نقل نوعيه في حياتها اذا كانت
مستعد يوصل لها السعاده احنا هون بنزرع
افكار بصراحه مش منطقين ما بدي احكي صح او
غلط بس هي مش منطقيه مش واقعيه فعليا هو
هو بيجيء كمان هو بده حاجات ويريد اشفاعها
مع هذا الكلام انه الطفل هذا صار سواء بنت
او ولد سيرين ان احنا نبقى نعطي له كثير
من الضربات همم يعني
هو في الصغر يعني الواحد في صغره بيعتقد
انه الدنيا كويسه انه ابوه وامه كويسين
وانه الحياه حلوه والحب حلو والاشياء دي
كلها مو ضروري نكسر له الافكار او نخليه
واقعي
الان ما بحكي لك هو هو المعيار انه هل راح
يتولد عندها هذه الفكره الفانتسيل الكثير
اللي هي خياليه جدا او لا حتى لا تصدم في
في الناس اللي راح تشوفهم تتعامل معهم
لاحقا حتى اني انا اعلمها انها تكون في
اللحظه انها تتعامل معه يعني يتم التعامل
معها تتعامل بناءا على اساس وما تتعامل
همم انه بصوره خياليه لانه انا بيجيني همم
ازواج وزوجات ال- بعد شهرين او ثلاثه من
الزواج
يعني متفاجئه مسروقه ما هي الحياه الزوجيه
طيب انت شو تصورتي الحياه انا فكرت انه
احنا رح نطلع نروح على المطعم ونلبس اواعي
حلوين ونشوف ناس حلوين وما توقعت انه كمل
مسؤوليه لها هذا عليك فهون انه لا مش
منطلق سلبي لا من منطلق واقعي انه انت
مقبره على حياتها طبعا كل العمر له
خصوصيته طريقه الشرح طريقه المعلومات
المعطاه وقديش قديش بدك تعطيها معلومات
وكان بالتفصيل وطريقه التفصيل
لا انا ممكن احافظ على ايجابيه ولكن با
يعني واقعي منطقي اوكي النفسيه
الصين
متصدرين الاخبار والعناوين السبب هو طبعا
طفرت كورونا جديده في الصين وخروج الجائحه
عن السيطره في بعض المناطق فامس اعلنتين
وفاه حالتين بكرونا وبالتالي صار عدد
الوفيات من اسابيع خمس وفيات هذا غير
الارتفاع في عدد حالات الاصابه بكوب 19
بشكل متسارع ومقلق فامس عدد الحالات 2000
حاله الصيدليات بتشكوا من نقص الادويه
محارق الجثث ملحقه على الوفيات ودول
العالم بدات تحذر من تاثير هذا الشيء على
باقي العالم المصيبه كمان انه في علماء او
بيقولوا انه هذه موجه اولى من بين ثلاث
موجات متوقعينها تضرب الصين في الشتاء
والسبب التفشي الجديده الان مو محدد او
معروف لكن الصين من اسابيع رفعت كل
الاجراءاتها وقودها صار ما لمواجهه كورونا
واللي فرضتها من ثلاث سنوات رفعتها
مظاهرات اتخللها شغب وعنف كبيرين من
الشعب اللي خلاص صراحه يعني وصل حده ومعاد
متحمل لنفسيا ولا اقتصاديا والاجتماعيا
ولا باي شكل يعني ومن بعد اسابيع كانت في
فيديوهات المظاهرات والاحتجاجات ضد قيد
كورونا في الصين ماليه المنصات اليوم
المسيطر فيديوهات موجعه على القلب صراحه
من مستشفيات ومراكز صحيه
اليوم
[موسيقى]
وكمان في فيديوهات متداوله على المنصات ما
بتختلف قسوتها عن اللي شفتوهم قبل وكمان
الفيديو حاصل على مليونير مشاهده وهو
للجثث كثيره مرميه في المستشفيات اللي
معاهد قادره خلاص انها تستقبل حالات زياده
فرونسي
[موسيقى]
وعلى برج هدف على طريق الملك فهد في
الرياض في عمل فني جميل اسير عيون المارين
من هناك كل شيء في الصور والمقاطع على
المنصات نحن بنتكلم عن جداريه عملاقه على
البرج للصوره للملك المؤسس عبد العزيز
الله الله يرحمه والجودريه طولها 120 متر
ومساحتها 1,220 متر مربع وصاحبها هو
الفنان محمد العمار احنا في تفاعلكم
توصلنا مع محمد وحدثنا عن موهبته في الرسم
اللي اكتسبها من الصغر وكيف بدا برسم
اللوحات ثم الشخصيات
الجداريه وحكى لنا كيف انه هو حلم سنوات
بانه يرسم رسمه عملاقه وما تخيل يجي له
برج قال كمان بتعبر عن الثقافه والحضاره
والالهام وقدره السعوديه على الصناعه
المستحيل امامكم الان هتشوفوا مشاهدينا
على الشاشه همم لقطات من مراحل انجاز
الجداريه
[موسيقى]
مشاهدينا وصلنا الى ختام حلقه اليوم انا
عود والقاكم غدا ان شاء الله في حلقه
جديده من تفاعلكم في امان الله
[موسيقى]